[Music]  Nicki Minaj is officially a single  ladies absolutely and I'll wear that  title proudly to the anaconda rapper has  called it quits with boyfriend meat meal  taking to social media Thursday morning  to set the record straight on split  rumors Nicki tweeted to confirm yes I am  single the star also teased new music  quote focusing on my work and looking  forward to sharing it with you guys  really soon have a blessed New Year love  you  he was the realness I was to bed and we  was the illest when he approached me  essential to Dylan the pair started  dating in early 2015 and Nicki first  fueled breakup rumors after posting this  pic to Instagram in December of Chanel  slippers she captioned the post I'm so  over you quoting Beyonce song best thing  I never had  [Music]  [Music]